For this course, we'll be working
pretty extensively with the idea
of a calendar and to-do list app.
This idea has certainly been done before
and you probably have some images in
your head of what an app
like this might look like.
Rather than relying on those though,
we'll be working from a set of mocks of
the sort you would have developed
in the product design course.
As you go through this class, remember
that each time you do something with
our example app, you can do the same
something with your own app idea
which will help you get started on
the final project for the course.
If you haven't taken the product design
course or haven't thought enough
about your app to make some very
rough mockups of the screens,
you'll benefit from taking a detour to
that class before you continue here.
If you have, take some time to
familiarize yourself with the mocks
which we've included below
the video in the classroom page.
The app design starts on this home
screen here, [SOUND] which is then
connected by a menu to all of
the other screens of the app.
Currently, we have a frequent action
button which connects to the new
events screen.
As you can see, we only have a basic
idea of what should go where.
We have a sense that there should be
multiple screens but we don't yet
have a sense of exactly
how they relate or
what the arrangement needs
to be on each screen.
Remember, you should be comfortable
throwing all this work away.
If we spend ten hours designing
the initial prototype,
we're going to have to throw
ten hours of work away.
If we spent ten minutes on it, that's an
amount of time that's easier to get rid.
And both will get a useful
feedback at this stage.